Yo,
what's your research paper called?
Hello world and a paper titled Everybody
Dance now out of UC Berkeley just
dropped and it's causing a lot of
hype in the Ai Community right now,
given a source video of a person dancing,
ideally a professional
for the best results.
They were able to transfer that dance
routine to another person called the
target.
After collecting just a few minutes of
training data from the target performing
standard moves, the implications
of this technology are profound.
It's like auto tune for dancing.
No longer do we necessarily need to be
able to dance well in order to create a
video of ourselves stancing
and notice that in their demo.
Although the output video is clearly
a bit pixelated and blurry to being
somewhat into the uncanny valley,
it was still able to generate even the
reflection of the dancer in the glass
behind him. Very impressive.
In the short term,
we'll likely see this technology be used
for casual consumption in the form of a
gift generating app or a snapchat filter.
People will use this as a fun pastime,
but as it gets better,
and it certainly will,
we'll start to see movie studios,
celebrities and advertising agencies
using it to help enhance their productions
in a low cost way.
Why hire an entire background dance
crew when you can just generate them?
A lead actor in a movie or a commercial
won't need intensive training to record
any dance sequence and because it can
lower costs so drastically expect to see
better quality content coming from the
immature video production community as
well. In a way, it democratizes
dance. The dark side of this,
just like the deep phase technology
that I explained a few months ago,
is that it's moving us towards a
world where any video evidence can be
manipulated, people can be framed
for crimes they didn't commit.
Anyone can use AI to synthesize
voices, faces, photos,
and now video.
So we'll need to create new
methods of identity verification.
Since video,
whether from a smartphone or a police
body cam is still the key make or break
element of many defense cases.
One solution is to use AI to
fight AI. In fact, giphy cat,
a popular video hosting
platform is already using AI
to classify videos is real
or fake. Another solution is
drum roll please. A blockchain,
a newer startup called factum has a
solution that's already been tested by the
Department of Homeland Security.
Since the Bitcoin blockchain is an
immutable data structure that no one can
modify. Factum is using it
to timestamp video data from,
say a security camera at specific
intervals because it digitally signs and
hashes data instantly. You're right. As
the pixels are pulled off the camera,
they can confidently claim that a video
was really taken by the camera that
digitally signed the data.
In general,
we can all use the blockchain to digitally
signed and confirm the authenticity
of a video file that relates to us.
The more people that add their
digital signature to a video,
the more valid it can be considered.
This kind of scheme,
we'll need to factor in the qualifications
of the people who sign a video file,
but it's promising.
So back to our researchers,
this is not the first attempt in this
field at creating new video content.
I manipulating existing video footage.
In 97 researchers created videos of
a subject saying a phrase they didn't
originally order I finding frames where
the mouth position matched the desired
speech.
In 2003 a group used optical flow as a
descriptor to match different subjects
performing similar actions.
More recently it was demonstrated that
deep learning techniques can help with
motion retargeting without supervised
data using generative adversarial nets.
This work was very likely
inspired by that one.
Our researchers split up their
training pipeline into three steps,
pose estimation, global
pose, normalization.
Then mapping from normalized posts,
stick figures to the target subject.
Let's go over each first pose estimation.
Once they found a suitable source
video of a professional dancer,
they needed to encode the body positions
of the source subject and what better
way to do that?
Then by using the pretrained
pose detector called open pose,
we can accurately estimate all of the
subjects multiple joint coordinates.
This is a convolutional neural network,
a specific series of matrix operations
that was optimized for pose estimation by
using the common strategy
of gradient descent.
They just downloaded the
pretrained weights file. In fact,
anyone can try out pose estimation in
the browser today and I actually have a
detailed video on how pose
estimation works already.
Link is going to be in
the video description.
They took those coordinates and drew
a representation of the resulting pose
stick figure by plotting the key points
and drawing lines between the connected
joints and because of video is just a
series of images in the form of video
frames.
They did this for every frame in the
video creating a rich dataset of dance
poses.
They then normalized each input image
to help account for the differences
between the source and target body
shapes and locations within the frame.
I analyzing joint positions for each
subject and using a linear mapping between
the closest and farthest angle positions.
In both videos.
They use this Dataset as input
to a generative adversarial
network for training.
The is composed of two neural
networks called the generator and the
discriminator.
The generator applies a
series of transforms to the
input image to produce the
output image.
The discriminators job is to then
perform a binary classification,
trying to discern if the
output image is real or fake.
That is if it's actually the target
subject dancing or a fake version.
The structure of the generator
is called an in coder decoder.
It takes the input image and tries
to compress it into a much smaller
representation using a series of incoders.
These are operational blocks consisting
of a convolution and an activation
function. The idea is that
by compressing it like this,
we can hopefully have a higher
level representation of the data.
After the final Incode layer.
The decode layers do the exact opposite
using operational blocks consisting of a
deconvolution and an activation function
and reverses the action of the encoder
layers.
A performance improvement here is to
directly connect the encoder layers to the
decoder layers using skip connections.
These skip connections give the network
the option of bypassing certain encoding
and decoding parts if it
doesn't have a use for it.
The specific type of Incode or decoder
architecture is called a you net.
Meanwhile, the discriminator
has the job of using two images,
one from the target video and one from
the generated output and deciding if the
second image was produced
by the generator or not.
It's a convolutional network
that structure looks similar
to the encoder section
of the generator works
a little differently.
The output is an image where each pixel
value represents how believable the
corresponding section of the unknown
image is. To train this network,
there are two steps.
Training the discriminator D and training
the generator g to train d first g
creates an output image,
the looks at the input target pair and
the input output pair and produces a
probability about how realistic they look.
The weights of d are then adjusted
based on the classification error of the
input output pair and the
input target pair. Geez.
Weights are then adjusted based on the
output of d as well as the difference
between the output and the target image.
Both the Angie will improve
over time during this process.
This training procedure
worked well enough,
but they found that the
generated dance video frames,
we're still kind of choppy and
didn't look very realistic,
so they added in two techniques can
portal smoothing and a facial GAM.
Instead of generating individual frames,
they modified their generator to predict
two consecutive frames where the first
output is conditioned on
its corresponding pose,
stick figure and the generated
frame at the previous time step.
The second output is conditioned on its
corresponding posts stick figure and the
first output.
So the discriminator was actually tasked
with determining both the differences
in realism and the tempur coherence
between the fake sequence and the real
sequence and to increase
the realism of the face.
They use an additional Ghana
specifically for generating faces.
Their model was able to create a
reasonably long video of a target person
dancing given body movements,
but the results still suffer from some
shakiness solutions to this could be to
use more training data.
Of course,
another would be to try out a different
normalization technique for both the
source and target videos.
Since the shakiness is likely a result
of the underlying differences between how
the source and target subjects move,
given their unique body structures or to
try out a different Gan loss function.
Since Gan research is
very active right now,
one only needs to glance@archivesanity.com
to see an example of what's being
done there.
Overall,
this research is very exciting and opens
up a lot of new possibilities for both
researchers and entrepreneurs.
Is this video real? Who knows?
Hit subscribe. Any way to stay
updated on my life's work. For now,
I've got to synthesize a new GPU,
so thanks for watching.